i'm janis dean i'm brett baer i'm martha
mccallum and this is the fox news
rundown
wednesday october 13 2021 i'm lisa brady
backed up ports and empty shelves a
supply chain issues and a labor shortage
continue what we should worry everyone
is how few workers are coming back into
the workforce we speak with texas
republican congressman kevin brady i'm
chris foster texas governor greg abbott
bans coronavirus vaccine mandates by
private businesses trump administration
surgeon general dr jerome adams says
that's the wrong approach so if you're
pro-business and if you're about letting
businesses do uh decide what's best for
them in their workforce then i think
you'd either you you got to live up to
it and i i just don't agree with the
idea of restricting businesses ability
to determine
what is best to keep their workforce
healthy
and i'm jason chaffetz i've got the
final word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
an issue becoming more obvious to
millions of americans is on president
biden's agenda today the empty spaces on
store shelves and the supply chain
bottlenecks causing it in california
alone dozens of container ships are
waiting for entry to the ports of los
angeles and long beach fox's william
laginess is there some of these ships
are taken two to three weeks to get into
la harbor to offload their stuff and
then over here you have trucking
problems right they tried to go 24 7
here in long beach and there weren't any
drivers to pick up the stuff now the
white house is set to announce an
expansion of 24 7 operations to the port
of la with a commitment from walmart
fedex and ups to work around the clock
as well sending a message it's time for
the rest of the goods chain to do it too
spokeswoman jensaki the president will
be meeting with the leadership of the
port of los angeles the port of long
beach and the international longshore
and warehouse union to discuss the
challenges at ports across the country
and actions each partner can take to
address these delays the supply chain
problems are largely considered to be a
pandemic ripple effect compounded by
millions of workers not returning to the
workforce but it's also fueling
inflation and more questions about the
president's agenda so i think we're
seeing the slowdown in jobs the
devastating worker shortage
and the higher prices all being driven
by washington and the white house texas
congressman kevin brady is the ranking
republican on the house ways and means
committee president biden's
nearly two trillion dollar coveted
stimulus
didn't create jobs he's nearly a million
jobs short of what he promised from that
worse
it didn't make it easier for our main
street businesses to hire
and we're seeing that continuing all up
and down the supply chain in fact
whether you're a small business or a big
manufacturing company you're not finding
the workers you need and that's driving
not just slower deliveries
and a slower recovery it's driving
prices up even higher and if president
biden and nancy pelosi get there
you know five trillion dollars or
whatever it is tax and spending bill
you're going to see both those problems
get worse you're going to see
fewer jobs you're going to see fewer
workers in the workplace you're going to
continue to see inflation which is on
track to be the highest rate in four
decades i think it's going to grow worse
on families and small businesses
what
should the government be doing if
anything
um to help address the labor shortage
and i asked that in part because you
know the extra unemployment benefits did
end um at least the extra ones from the
federal government
um
but yet the labor shortage persists yeah
so what this should worry everyone
because what we saw in september besides
you know most economists couldn't
believe
september could be worse in august as a
jobs report so they dumbed out
expectations in in that it even fell
below that but what we should worry
everyone is how few workers are coming
back into the workforce and the ones who
are are 55 or older so this is not what
the government says people are just
retiring it's really just the opposite
so here's what washington
should do which is one refocus on
defeating the virus and rebuilding the
economy so you know stop all the
discussion about these impending tax
hikes on small businesses on american
companies trying to compete on families
and middle class stop that it's having
an effect secondly
stop paying people more to stay home
than to reconnect with work even though
the federal unemployment bonuses went
away in september there are two new
barriers that president biden put in
place which is
this new child tax credit which by the
way was created in 1997 by republicans
to help families offset the cost of
raising kids but also as part of our
welfare reform reconnecting people to
work and lifting them out of poverty for
the first time now this year
the child tax credit no longer requires
you to work or have any earnings
whatsoever this creates just another
welfare
uh program we're already hearing from
main street businesses they're losing
workers
because of this new child tax credit and
how it's paid out the other thing is the
obamacare subsidies for covid they
expanded them lifted the cap so right
now
it made them more generous so right now
you can get jobless
uh as good or better healthcare
by not returning to work than going back
to work so you've got in place the
federal employment bonuses you now have
two programs that again make it so much
more difficult for main street
businesses to find the workers they need
that too
is driving up prices as well
i hear republicans like yourself
arguing against
a shift toward an entitlement
mentality and entitlement type society
but is it mostly
democrats just negotiating with each
other at this point about the level of
spending that's being proposed and not
really about shifting priorities yeah it
is
they are trying to figure out how to
stuff
as many of their tax increases which is
crippling and as many of the expansion
of the welfare state into that one and a
half or so trillion dollars i will tell
you
that you can do just as much economic
damage
to main street into america within one
and a half trillion dollars you can
plant the seeds on these welfare and
entitlement programs that grow into
massive forests in the future that we
can never afford to pay for within that
smaller package so republicans don't
have the votes to stop this by ourselves
but we are focusing in leading an effort
to convince
moderate democrats in the house
to step up to stop
these tax increases
in in spending programs that drive up
inflation you know we convinced two
house democrats to do that in committees
we only need three
to stop this
bill in the house
you know the question is
are there moderate democrats left
who will step up for their local small
businesses defend american jobs and say
no to the spending we're going to
continue
to focus to try to stop this in the
house
is there any amount of spending on the
so-called human
infrastructure side the president's
social agenda
that you would consider supporting
you know going through that two thousand
four hundred pages
it's been difficult for me
to find
programs that are
such a high priority that would you
would raise taxes to pay for them i
haven't seen any in there
and in truth i think they work against
lifting americans out of poverty in the
long term we saw this under republican
tax reform and president trump by
lowering our taxes and redesigning our
codes so america could compete and win
anywhere in the world what we saw
you know a year after it was in place
2019 we saw
households families
they they gained more in their family
budget higher paychecks in one year
than in all eight years under president
obama so we know the solution to some of
the biggest problems of lifting people
out of poverty don't come from
government checks that never end they
come from good job opportunities and
rising paychecks
are you
at all concerned though that that kind
of republican message
isn't as easy as a cell maybe to the
american public as but everybody should
have universal pre-k
yeah so i think they're counting look
anything that's free is normally very
popular and if you can tax you know the
wealthy and the big corporations all
that sounds very very popular until you
get into the details and then when you
realize that this drives u.s jobs
overseas and raise taxes on middle class
americans when people start to
understand that
this welfare state is something that
will hurt americans going forward
you know especially
if kids don't see their parents working
you change the whole foundation the
united states we're seeing more and more
polls that show
more americans learn about what's in
this bill the less popular it is
your home state texas remains on the
front lines of the migrant surge
that continues
do you hear from constituents about that
or are they more concerned with how much
they're paying for gasoline right now
all the above uh it is we've never seen
anything like this in our lifetime uh
and and it is getting worse not better
in that
as a state as a border state we pay for
our communities pay a pretty steep price
in in
uh illegal drug activity uh we see it in
sex trafficking houston region
regrettably is the number one sex
trafficking region in in the country
we're seeing it with criminal gangs
property uh damage all of that
in a state like ours so yeah texans are
are laser focused on that because we
take the brunt of it but the other point
too yeah
look inflation as i said on track to be
the the highest in 40 years
we're seeing this in every aspect of
uh families lives i noticed a new study
just you know a few days old shows that
because inflation is so high an average
family like a teacher
salary is paying an extra cell phone
bill a month or an extra utility bill a
month or an extra cable bill a month
just because the inflation that they've
seen since president biden has taken
office so
and i'm i'm convinced the new spending
and taxing will make that worse for
families
we're heading
toward what feels like kind of an
uncertain holiday season again even as
coveted cases finally start to come down
from the delta surge
what do you say who
you know to constituents or anyone
who are worried about the direction of
the country right now
there is a reason
president biden has lost america's
confidence in the economy
uh in his handling of the border
of the surrender to the taliban in
afghanistan
and this overall the competency of this
white house is because the decisions
he's making and the issues he's ignoring
i think this is
going to lead to a very strong
republican majority in the house
elections next november and perhaps in
the senate
as well
um americans
this is not what they were sold
on
last election i noticed about one out of
every five
voters who voted for president biden now
regret that decision
uh and in washington i'll just tell you
i've never seen a more partisan
white house that refuses to work
together on any issue
for the american people it's not what
the president stood up and talked about
uh on
as he was sworn in so yeah there are a
lot of red flags that's why i think
there are moderate democrats in the
house who understand now they are on
their own president's not backing them
speaker police are not backing them the
liberal progressives aren't backing them
that's why i think we have a chance
at defeating this massive tax and
spending bill because
you know what few month democrats your
life understand they won't be returning
if they vote for that
massive bill
texas republican congressman kevin brady
thanks very much for your time
thank you lisa take care
[Music]
this is jason chaffetz with your fox
news commentary coming up
workplace coronavirus vaccine mandates
have largely been persuading people to
get the shots the white house report
finds that businesses requiring that
employees be vaccinated or put up with
regular testing and stricter safety
measures have vaccination rates above 90
percent not everyone's going along with
it some people are giving up their jobs
rather than get the shots including jobs
and health care so i'm a doctor i still
practice
and i think that the burden on someone
who is caring for people who are
vulnerable and who come in
expecting not to be exposed is one
consideration so i actually very much
agree with the concept of mandates in
health care settings because we need to
protect people dr jerome adams was
surgeon general of the united states
during the trump administration now
director of health equity initiatives at
purdue university many people have heard
me say consistently that we should not
go to mandates unless and until we've
got a healthy dose of education and
engagement to go along with it it
shouldn't just be bullying someone into
doing something it should be reaching
out to women and making sure they
understand that vaccines don't cause
fertility issues it should be reaching
out to african americans who have
distrust because of tuskegee and helping
them understand the protections that are
in place so so
i say all that because i think it's
important that we understand
that this all or none either your four
mandates or your or your for letting
people do whatever
is not really the answer there's nuance
in between yeah don't believe top-down
government um really um engages people
but i do believe that employers
should be able to decide what's best for
their workplace which is what concerns
me when i see what's going on around the
country and particularly in texas out
right now
yeah i mean that decision from governor
greg abbott
that you're talking about this executive
order banning any entity in texas even
private businesses from acquiring
vaccinations for
employees or for their customers
that could affect some of their bottom
lines
so you think it even even though
philosophically you may agree that
people should have their freedom
businesses you think should be able to
do what they want to again to protect
their bottom line
well exactly that's what it comes down
to if you're pro-business and if you're
about letting businesses do decide
what's best for them and their workforce
then i think you've either you you've
got to live up to it and i i just don't
agree with the idea of restricting
businesses ability to determine what is
best to keep their workforce healthy
another interesting point is that we are
having real trouble recruiting people
back into the workforce and a lot of
that's because people are worried about
coronavirus and so one of the things
workplaces are doing is trying to create
an atmosphere of safety to get people
back to work and we're all going to
suffer if we can't create a safe
workplace and a workplace where people
feel comfortable coming into yeah i mean
and you've alluded to the the people not
getting the vaccines they're not all the
same for a lot of them these workplace
mandates or other mandates are enough to
say oh fine who cares i'll just get the
shots it's fine others feel like look
rightly or wrongly they feel like
there's some risk to getting the shot
and it's just not worth it they don't
think kovac 19's serious enough
they just might want and need just more
information and not to be harangued
about it and then you've got the few who
are going to say look no way know how
i'm never going to get it those
obviously have to put to the side
i couldn't agree more i think that we
have allowed ourselves to believe that
the majority of people who are
unvaccinated are in this um what some
people call anti-backs i don't use that
term i consider it pejorative but
vaccine resistant group it's really only
about five to ten percent of people who
are in that immovable group most of the
people who were unvaccinated are people
who just are fearful mistrustful haven't
had time to get their questions answered
some of them haven't had the ability to
get vaccinated and i know that's hard to
believe but you still have people who um
are
aren't able to take time off from work
to get vaccinated or worried about
vaccine side effects so the more that we
can address those real concerns those
real barriers the more we'll win people
over and i think when you couple that
with mandates in some instances then the
mandates go a lot more smoothly than
when it just seems like someone
from top down from washington dc is
saying i'm going to make you do
something especially when it seems
politically motivated yeah i don't know
quite what the answer is to some of
those people but some of us more
fortunate of us may forget look if
you're a
housekeeper for example or i don't know
whatever it is
you may not be able to afford to take a
day off or some time off to get the
vaccine and you certainly don't want to
take off a day or two in case you have
some side effects
well there's a lot of people who work in
the gig economy who we often forget
about are uber drivers and uh and like
you said people who are who are day
laborers and and they don't have paid
time off so that's a big part of it but
there are also people who are caregivers
for children or caregivers for elderly
folks or disabled folks and they simply
are fearful that if they have vaccine
side effects they won't be able to meet
their obligations and so we need to
understand that we need to approach
people with
compassion and i found that when i do
that i i've won more people over
than uh than people who just say no i
absolutely don't want to don't want to
hear from you i think that's important
for us to remember another thing that's
critical
is when you look at flu vaccination
rates for last year we actually had a
record flu vaccination rate last year
and it was at about 55
we're already past that for covet
vaccinations so we always knew that when
you hit about 60 to 70 percent
vaccination rates things were going to
level off it was going to shift from
this era of open up the football stadium
and there's lines and people coming to
get vaccinated to really this one-on-one
approach that we've got to take right
now and so i really am frustrated at the
politicization of this um by all sides
um and you know this idea that hey it's
just a bunch of republican um back with
jokes who don't want to get vaccinated
no this isn't about politics it's about
mistrust and misinformation even though
some of these workplace mandates are
working some of them aren't southwest
airlines pilots for example have spoken
up about not wanting to have this
vaccine mandate and now there's you know
slow downs the company says it's not
about vaccine mandates about other stuff
but in any case what do you do
when and if these mandates
shut down industry we've also talked
about more importantly healthcare
workers especially nurses not getting
the shots are you concerned about
shortages
there
terribly concerned and and i've tweeted
about this frequently it really
frustrates me when these health care
institutions and other institutions go
out and say we only only lost 100 nurses
we only lost 150 people due to vaccine
mandates to me that's a loss anytime
you're losing health care workers in the
midst of a crisis
that is a loss and what i want to know
is what are the demographics of that
group how many of them are women who
were just scared how many of them are
african-americans or hispanics or people
of color
who who are
diversifying our workforce in a in a
very needed way that we're now losing
and if companies aren't reporting on
that then they shouldn't be out there
applauding the fact that uh that it's
only been 50 or 100 or so people and i
also think it goes back to what i said
earlier
is that the places that have
successfully implemented mandates are
the ones that coupled it with heavy
doses of education throughout so that
you got to a point where people really
did understand okay you made an honest
attempt
a real real genuine attempt to reach out
to me and you're just not going to win
me over and so okay we're going to part
ways
i mean that education has been a big
part of the military vaccine mandate
where they we're not going to
dishonor we discharge you on day one
we're going to sit you down we're going
to talk to you and try to give you some
information and it's getting better some
service branches are lagging behind
others what would you be doing what
could you be doing to ease those
concerns for service people
the surgeon general i was the head of
the united states public health service
commission corps and that's always been
a concern that we had that we didn't
want to push people away who committed
to serving their country
and we didn't we know that particularly
younger people people who tend to join
the military child bearing age on people
who are healthier
they're people who we always knew we
were going to have a hard time winning
over because they're the people who are
least likely to get their flu shots and
their other shots they think they're
young and invincible in many cases and
we need to help them understand the
benefits of vaccination that it makes
our country safer
that it makes our country more secure
that it helps keep you healthy and keep
people around you healthy that it
actually preserves your fertility the
food and drug administration and centers
for disease control are expected to
approve pfizer's coronavirus vaccine for
five to eleven-year-old sometime between
halloween and thanksgiving some kids
that age do get sick from coba 19 and
hospitalization rates have gone up
especially in states with lower
vaccination rates since school started
666 kids under the age of 18 have died
of covid since the start of the pandemic
according to the centers for disease
control but most cases are mild or
asymptomatic and the data shows even
unvaccinated kids are less at risk for
serious covenant infection than a
vaccinated 70 year old for example we
need to understand that kids don't exist
in a bubble they exist around other
adults they exist around teachers and
we're hearing just horrible horrible
statistics from around the country from
places like florida of the number of
teachers who've died and you can't have
a class if your teachers are being
exposed and infected and so uh once
again we have to understand that you get
kids vaccinated number one because we
can never predict who's gonna be that
one in one thousand and you never wanted
to be your kid i mean most kids who ride
a bicycle don't die but i still think
it's appropriate for them to wear a
helmet most kids who ride in a car don't
die on car wrecks but it's appropriate
for them to wear seat belts it's
appropriate because we don't know who's
going to be that person but that said we
also know that these kids are the major
vectors that right now of spreading the
virus and causing us to have to close
schools down uh keep communities closed
so there are social benefits to everyone
in addition to the individual benefits
and it's why i'm going to get my
daughter vaccinated my 11 year old my 15
and 17 year olds already are but as soon
as i'm eligible i'm a doctor i've looked
at the facts i'm going to get my
daughter back to keep her safe and to
keep our community open
dr adams one more question for you as we
as we move forward into this phase of
people are always going to get sick with
this people are always going to die of
this but we're just going to have to
learn to live with it we're not going to
have hospitals
crammed
when and how does it start looking like
normal even
when this acceptance comes when when are
kids not going to wear masks in school
when are we not going to wear masks on
planes anymore or is it just going to be
case by case forever
um as is hot spots pop up
well i'm actually optimistic i am
optimistic because between this delta
surge which unfortunately has taken a
lot of lives and uh the increasing
vaccination rates ever increasing
vaccination rates i think we are getting
to a degree of herd immunity in many
places that will allow this to become
more like the flu and what do i mean
there i mean that most people who get it
will have a mild cold they'll feel
crappy for a little bit but they'll be
okay
we are i think getting there and what we
need to do is concentrate on getting the
rest of the world vaccinated so that we
don't get a variant that pops up and
comes back over here but i think i
honestly do think that by early next
year we're going to start to see things
returning to much more normalcy and in
many cases around the country like i
said you see football games packed you
see uh concerts people are getting back
to normal and they're getting back to
normal because they're vaccinated we're
getting the herd immunity things are
returning to what we would like them to
be all right i'm gonna stop this because
there was an optimistic answer and
that's where i want to walk away from
this today
dr jerome adams uh the 20th surgeon
general of the united states director of
health equity initiatives at purdue
university dr adams thank you very much
hope to talk to you soon hey thank you
chris get the facts and then hopefully
you will get your backs that's how we
get out of this
[Applause]
[Music]
did you hear the news now you can with
instant updates from fox news for amazon
alexa just say alexa play news from fox
in fox news it's the latest when you
need it on demand from fox news and
amazon alexa subscribe to this podcast
at
foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
what's on your mind as the natural
consequences a bad public policy
continue their inevitable assault on the
american economy democrats with national
ambitions are going to be increasingly
reluctant to let voters pin joe biden's
tale on their donkey this may help
explain why the president is not getting
a lot of help even from his own inner
circle we aren't getting the plans we
were promised instead we're getting thin
smoke and faded mirrors that aren't
fooling anyone joe biden may be aging
and confused but what's the excuse for
vice president harris's failure to
address the border crisis secretary
boudij's failure to contain the shipping
crisis or secretary blinken's failure to
bring americans home from a war zone
democratic gubernatorial candidate terry
mcauliffe last week said the quiet part
out loud at a virginia virtual campaign
rally
quote we are facing a lot of headwinds
from washington as you know the
president is unpopular today
unfortunately here in virginia so we've
got to plow through and quote
no kidding almost everything this
administration has touched has spiraled
out of control spending inflation the
pandemic crime supply chains terrorism
the list goes on
but the people biden has chosen to
oversee these problems are either awol
or in full on spin mode
we can't afford to let biden's
hand-picked inner circle distance
themselves from the disastrous
presidency they enabled
take vice president kamala harris she
was supposed to be a safe pick someone
the president could count on to lobby
her senate colleagues and get deals done
where has she been during the democrats
failing attempts to ram through their
progressive spending wish list
absent
polls show the biden harris
administration policies on crime
immigration energy and terrorism are
deeply unpopular and more likely to be
seen as destroying america than saving
it meanwhile as container ships line up
at our ports goods sit on docks
undelivered and the trucking industry
experiences a historic labor shortage
transportation secretary pete buttige
has been curiously silent as fox's
martha mccallum recently noted
where is the rest of joe biden's support
team
it's as if people on biden's team are
seeing the carnage of his policies and
saying to themselves
you won't pin this on me
it seems there is no donkey in the
democratic party who wants to be pinned
with the unpopular outcomes of this
president's policies
i'm jason chaffetz fox news contributor
a distinguished fellow for the
government accountability institute
and the host of the jason in the house
podcast
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
i'm guy benson join me weekdays at 3 p.m
eastern as we break down the biggest
stories of the day with some of the
biggest newsmakers and guests listen
live on the fox news app or get the free
podcast at guybensonshow.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes